ce 7 février port au prince a été agitée
par les tensions politiques
manifestants et forces de l'ordre se
sont affrontés dans la capitale
haïtienne les jets de pierres répondant
aux tirs de grenades lacrymogènes en
cause un désaccord sur la date de fin du
mandat de jeu venail moïse selon les
manifestants le président a ici un très
impopulaire aurait outrepassé la fin
officielle de son mandat
tout le monde peut voir que le mandat du
président est terminée ils profitent
juste de l'absence du parlement par
conséquent le président ne peut toujours
rien faire même s'ils concluent des
accords politiques c'est son mandat qui
a pris fin aujourd'hui j'ai vu comment
ils nous ont massacrés avec des gaz
lacrymogènes la population nous a dit
que le mandat de jovenna elle est
terminée nous ne quitterons pas les rues
avant qu'il n'ait quitté le pouvoir des
manifestants déterminés à pousser je
vénère moïse à rendre les clés du pays
mais pour les autorités cette
manifestation derrière manque une
tentative de coup d'état
je ne suis pas un dictateur
les dictateurs sont des gens qui
prennent le pouvoir et ne savent pas
quand ils vont partir je sais que mon
mandat prend fin le 7 février 2022 le
chef d'état haïtien avait été élu pour
cinq ans lors d'un scrutin annulé pour
fraude fin 2015 puis réélu en a plus
tard il a prêté serment le 7 février
2017 et considère que ce mandat a
commencé à partir de cette date
le président haïtien qui assure avoir
échappé à une tentative d'assassinât
au total 23 personnes ont été arrêtées
ce dimanche selon les autorités
alors dimanche de violence qui découle
d'une longue crise politique depuis un
an dans haïti est privé de parlements
jovenna moïse gouverner par décret
alimentant un peu plus la défiance de la
population à son égard
[Applaudissements]